Alright, hello everyone, thank you and
welcome to our session.
We really appreciate you being here with us today
on your last day of reinvent. How's
it going out there?
You still have the same energy you brought to day one?
Yeah, OK,
so, hi, I'm Joel. For this session we're gonna
do something pretty different than
you would normally see
in a lot of these sessions
because, um, I, I, I'm with
GLA. We're gonna talk about AI
and Glean and fun things like that, but
I don't think that's nearly as interesting as talking to
smart people who are in the process of deploying AI
or have deployed AI
and talking to them about what they've seen, done,
and know.
So, um, I'm just looking at how many people
are here in this room.
We're gonna ask some questions
of these, of our illustrious panel here
who I have introduced themselves in a second,
um, and we've got some prompts for them to start
talking about it, but I would love your feedback.
We have one little problem which is,
I don't have a mic to go hold to you,
so if you have a, and I can't really see you very well
because it's very bright,
but.
I would love you to have the opportunity
to ask questions of our panel as well
so if you have something like that, you can either step
forward or if you shout it loud enough I can hear it. I'll
repeat it
so that so that everyone can hear it well
but um
with that I think let's get started and
talk a little bit about who's who. So maybe
um Marcel we can start with you and we can do
just a quick introduction as we go down the
line. Absolutely,
uh, Marcel Pivotal, I'm a solutions
architect with Glenn.
Um, I've been on the
technology space for about 20 something years
doing a lot of networking implementation
across multiple hyper scalers.
Um, I was for about 5 years,
uh, in AWS doing traditional
machine learning implementation and
for the last 2 years,
uh, doing
generative AI workflows,
uh, across multiple verticals with
AWS and with Glen.
Nice to meet you all.
Good afternoon,
everyone. I am Rohit Bala Subramanyan.
I'm with Deloitte.
I have been with Deloitte for
about 28 years now,
uh, which flew in a flash, I guess.
I've grown up in technology, just
like uh the illustrious panel here.
I've done a bunch of things, as you can imagine, beginning
with ERP,
data warehousing, and business intelligence when that
was a big thing.
Uh, I've helped stand up our big
data business.
I helped run our cloud business,
and now I'm looking to
bravely take the charge into
selling services around AI and Agentic
AI. Very happy to be here and
looking forward to this conversation. Absolutely.
Thank you. Um, good afternoon,
everyone. My name is Ravia Mamou, Senior
Director at uh Docusain.
Um,
my experience,
you know, goes along the same way,
with the other two gentlemen, 20+ years.
I started in the database
technology, so, so very well.
Uh, burst with the, the database technologies,
data platforms.
In the last few years when, you know,
the whole thing about
G A into pictures, so me and my team have
reskilled ourselves to deploy
many pervasive AI tools and capabilities
to the company
and building the agents
and deploying the solutions
itself to the company. So we'll talk more about
that. So
for, for those of you who are who are are interested,
this is how we sort of set this up. Ravi
is in the middle of deploying right now
and working with his team and leading them
to really doing AI
for real,
for DocuSign in a meaningful way.
And Rohit
has seen it done a bunch of times
at Deloitte across a bunch of customers
and Marcel
has seen it done.
With AWS systems very extensively
so this is why we've brought these folks
in to to sit with you and
to talk through some of the questions we have. So let's start
with our first prompt here
and let's talk about uh
about the popularity of
let me see if I can make that happen.
Let's talk about the popularity of
AI and where it's going right now. So here's
a quote from Gartner
about, uh, enterprise software applications
including agentic AI. And so I guess my
question would be
maybe we can start with you, Rohi, right? Like.
Are you seeing people today
really deploying
AI across?
10%, 5% of their decision making?
How, how pervasive is it today
in, in where people are using? It's a great
question, and I'll give you um
a couple of
thoughts on that, right?
We As you would expect
as a professional services firm,
we work across
a whole host of industries and
in my role,
you know, I play across industries.
So, when I look at
this question,
I absolutely see
AI in different forms,
not just agentic,
Machine learning,
plus plus plus, now to agentic
playing in
life sciences.
Uh, we see it clearly in financial services,
banking and insurance.
Um, so yes, it is pervasive
across industry and industry sectors.
The,
the interesting thing is when I looked at
this quote here, about
33% of
software applications, enabling 15%,
you know,
are we there as yet?
I don't think so,
right? But I definitely think
that Agente is here to
stay and grow,
and this will only, you know, gather
momentum as we come.
But so, to sum up,
pervasive across
industry sectors with certain sectors leading.
And this is definitely the the the trend
that we see.
So, Robbie, I mean, obviously you're,
you're in the thick of things
at DocuSign.
We, we all sort of are thinking our, our peers
are doing it, our competitors are doing it, our employees are
doing it whether we like it or not.
Um,
uh, what, what do you, what are your
goals here?
Like how much of
work do you think AI is gonna be able to take over
for your team? How realistic is it that it
will be able to take it over
meaningfully soon?
Yeah, I'm, um, you know, I'm just not going to
talk just for me and my team
because we have been working
with um a lot of different
organizations within Tussain.
I'll just, um, see what I'm, I'll
just say what I'm seeing,
you know, within,
um, the organizations, right? So,
so definitely, I see the shift.
Yeah, a lot is happening and if you look at
like, you know, a few years before,
there were a lot of hesitations,
right, to use
the AI because, you know,
what we are uploading,
what the, you know, models will do and things like
that, right? Uh, we have come a
long way, but, um, if you
look at it, we are actually said that,
oh let's do the, you know, AIA
first mind mindset strategy,
right? And with that, what
we are saying,
everyone in the company or, you know, my
team also,
that
whatever you do, you know, how can
you think of
doing fast with the AI?
Right, now, having said that, you know,
I know these percentages may have come up with,
uh, some surveys,
but, but, you know,
will, will we, will we be there at
that percentage? I don't know,
but the shift is definitely happening, happening,
and we have deployed a lot of tools
and we also have built a lot of
tools
and we are in the thick of
developing the agents for multiple,
you know, business processes and so on. So I
see the shift is happening.
But one thing that I want to highlight with
respect to
um
the autonomous agents,
you know,
that's where
I think we are thinking a lot, can that be
really autonomous?
And
I'm not seeing that right now
on the agency that we're building, but can we go
there? We believe it can be,
but um for that, I think a lot of LLMs
are actually maturing
and when we
see the shift is happening from maybe
from probabilistic to deterministic
model. You know, we, we'll be able to
take those decisions very confident
confidently is what I'm thinking.
You know, I see that there's, there's actually
a, a semantic challenge
with this emerging space of AI
around this term autonomous.
So, um,
I, I know that it can mean two things. One
thing it can mean that the agent is actually
taking action and doing stuff without human intervention.
Um, but there's also a second way just for
everyone here that people, um, in the AI
space are using it and that is as a, uh,
agents that are able to sort of think and
plan for themselves and evaluate their work on their own,
but they still require human intervention too,
um. So,
um, Marcel, I guess my question for you
is. Is autonomous
like true autonomy where it does everything
without human intervention? Is that to, to
Robbie's point, he's like, mm not so sure on
that. What, what are your thoughts there?
Yeah, what I, what I've been seeing across multiple
customers is
focusing on the business outcome,
uh, and
depending on the level of the agent,
you may have some level of
complete automation.
But the reality is that today human
in the loop is critical, evaluation is
critical,
making sure that you, the
outcome that you're receiving
is validated,
uh, so not only through a pilot
phase but also when you move that into
production, you need to have a pipeline
that you're able to make sure
that your agent is behaving as expected
and as that progresses
and you earn more trust,
then you may be coming into an autonomous
agent.
Um,
but I will say
I have seen few use cases
that are completely autonomous and,
and few that we might be comfortable
with allowing to run without
human overview.
Yeah, thank you for that. I'm gonna try this
button again here. I may need to stand up.
So, you were all talking a little bit
about, you talked about trust and we were talking about
several other components here. There's a quote from
our CEO founder, right,
but about organizational complexity
being the biggest challenge. So,
so
Oh, so Robbie,
organizational complexity or clicker complexity
being a big bottleneck, um.
How are you addressing this idea of
true transformation, right?
Because it's such a people-based, trust-based,
behavior-based
item, and
How complex an organization is and how an
organization works is like the thumbprint of that org,
right? How,
how are you thinking about organizational complexity
versus
model,
like your technical coolness of
what's going on in AI.
Yeah, so definitely, right, I think, um, you
know, some of you,
you know, maybe coming from startup to
mid-size versus uh very, you
know, large size organizations.
I truly believe that the complexities,
you know, proportional to, in my opinion,
the size of the organizations, right?
Um, but having said that, I just want
to go back where we started the
journey. So at that time when, you
know, Open a GPT model 33.5
was released.
You know, there was only a very small team,
you know, going back and exploring what is
it about
and you know how can we use that effectively and
so on, but very soon every
single team started to play around and
things like that
that that brought a challenge
which is basically,
you know, how many tools are there for the same,
you know, for, for solving the same
type of the problem,
you know, multiple teams would come back
with the different products available in the market.
So one is the clear boundaries
of who wants what,
right? So that's the, that's one of the things,
you know, is helping us. Otherwise,
it's kind of the, you know,
everyone is trying to do everything.
But the second one was that also brought
other challenges. OK, so we
brought multiple different tools out there,
but how do we take those tools,
those tools to the, you know, the teams
or other organizations and so on.
And the challenge what we have seen is,
oh, can you give me a blueprint of
when should I use which models? I'm getting confused.
OK, you are using,
you know, Google Gemini, when should I use
it, or Notebook Gla, when should I use it?
Or we have built our own,
no, um, you know, internal kind of the
JGPD
with all the models available. So when should I use
it? Then we are actually,
we were actually exploring enterprise
search tools.
Um, which is actually very interactive,
personalized, and things like that, right? So when
we are bringing that many tools to the
users, they were really confused as
well, right?
And the other aspect of it is,
um, you know, how do you enable them?
How do you train them,
and how do you develop the
responsible AA policies
and things like that. So,
those were, you know, some of the challenges
that what we have seen.
In the organization, but on the other hand, the
models we look at it, we started with 3.3,
3.5. Now, we are seeing
all the way up to 5.1,
then Gemini Gemini 3, so
it's evolving very fast, but
sometimes, you know,
these complexities
preventing us to, you know,
run at the same speed.
So I think we had to be,
you know,
aware of the fact that.
You know, the training is needed, you
know, the, you know, multiple approval
is needed across
security, legal, and things like that. So, if
you take care of that, I think this complexity
can be minimized to some extent.
So one of the aspects of organizational complexity
that I've seen a lot is, and, and
probably Marcel you've, you've seen this too, is
who owns what part of what tools,
who's willing to give you API access to
their walled garden of tools, and that's
inside an organization, right?
Um, you might say, oh well, I think that SAS
tool is owned by
that department now I have to go ask them
if I can get access for my AI
tools because I'm trying,
uh, uh, I'm
trying to synthesize these things together and to a
certain extent the.
The AI initiative becomes the
forcing factor of
an integrated workflow that probably should have been
there beforehand
but isn't because people are busy and they're working
in their own, their own groups, right?
Absolutely. So I can add 11
example right when we recently came with
the MCP strategy,
right. So where do we host it? Who wants
it? Who will create the custom MCP servers
and things like that? So
a lot going on there. So yeah,
I'm a strong believer that, um,
organizational,
um, technical
technical
complexity mirrors organizational
complexity. So
the tools are there and normally as you
go and implement those
you will implement it as your
organization growth so you will have data silos
you will have governance problems so
security is your best friend.
On this situation, you need to
work with security from day one
to be able to go across those
data silos and those accesses
so you will be able to share
that context into uh
your agentics, you know,
the frontier models,
they move real quick like every other month
we have a new model,
but what really holds you down
is the complexity that you have on your
organization and how you bubble up that
data into the models.
So, Rohit, I know you've seen,
because you've come from a data and analytics space
where every team has their data.
How do we convince teams to work
better together, how to integrate
and allow for the synthesis of their stuff, that
that was what makes AI work? Absolutely.
I mean, you hit the nail on the head when you talked
about, use the word synthesis, right?
EI
And agentic especially.
is not about
Bolting an AI solution to a
legacy.
scenario.
It's actually about reimagining
workflows, reimagining
processes,
and so when you, and that's really when you
get the
true bang for the buck and the true
value uplift.
And so,
by definition,
Reimagining or re-engineering
processes
to judiciously put in
AI.
Involves
business stakeholders,
has to involve data stakeholders,
has to involve technology, has to involve
almost every part of an organization,
right? So by definition,
there's got to be a very strong
AI or analytics strategy
which calls out the active
participation of all of these stakeholders
in various
levels of degree across the life cycle of.
Even a use case implementation.
So, we've
also learned, you know, after stumbling
in the first few
years,
we've also learned, uh, you know, how
to refine
our professional services,
the strate the strategic part of what we offer.
And one of the things we
keep front and center
is,
you know, a strategic approach to
roadmaps.
A strategic approach to
business value capture right at
the beginning in terms of defining what
the success criteria are,
a very strategic and comprehensive
approach to making sure that
multiple stakeholders are gonna be part of the plan,
and then you go about delivering it.
You know, I'll hark back to the
33% and the 15%
numbers which were all positive and it's all good,
but we also know
that. You know,
what, what was this? As of last year,
some 90% of,
uh, yeah,
projects were failing.
And There are many reasons for
that, but I think right at the core,
the reason was that, you know, all
the different pieces that needed to play
nicely to actually make this a success
wasn't in place in different organizations.
That realization is coming now,
which is why we're seeing the uptick in these numbers
and which is why we're seeing some greater implementations.
Yeah, the, the research is very, very clear
here that AI does better
when it is fed the right relevant context.
And that that context does not exist in one
system. And so we have a real
problem where the technology is
forcing the change in the
organization, because
the answers you get from AI if it's based on
one tool, one data set, one silo,
are not super useful.
And so
we end up having, if we're talking
about really implementing AI
and really transforming orgs towards AI
now we have to make a very
different.
Business decision about how we operate,
which is
hard. It's way harder than paying
some vendor some money to get AI,
right? Like, like paying some vendor to
get some money to get AI is relatively trivial.
Um, I will say this, this is, this
is an important point that I think this slide brings up for
me, and maybe we'll see a show of hands
out there and I'll try and do this. Um, who
thinks OpenAI has the best LLM
model right now?
OK, no hands. All right,
uh, Google and Gemini, like anybody?
Yeah, I got a couple of hands,
uh, Claude,
anthropic?
Anybody? I see a couple of
years, yeah, so I always ask that question and then I say, OK,
in 18 months who do you think is gonna have
the best model.
We don't know, and
everybody chuckles, right, because we, we don't know. And
so I think one thing to think about this too is
if you over rotate on which model, if
you spend
a ton of money buying a model,
you will almost certainly be disappointed
because we are in a horse race and you're
betting on who's gonna win, and that means a
lot of people. People are gonna lose.
And so when you're deploying this, I think Robbie,
like you're talking about
multiple tries and how we get it in multi-threaded
and and wrote it around the
organization, right? It's really important to be
open and have an open ecosystem
so that you can choose it.
AI is not done.
The innovation is not done. It's accelerating and
so that's just one takeaway from
here. Now we
talk and it just works like a charm this time
by the way. I don't
you have the magic touch, um.
So, so here's a quote from HBR right
about compatibility issues and data silos.
So.
This process redesign, I think we've been talking
about quite a bit.
But how are,
how are Marcel, how are you seeing.
This idea of needing to interconnect all that
data working
technically,
right, because that's a non-trivial technical challenge
as well,
yeah, absolutely. I, I think that a
few, a few things here. One is,
um, you have the traditional connectors
that connects to your data sources in.
Test all that data,
you know, kind of merge that together
and give you context,
uh, but in the last few
months we have seen MCPs
coming into place,
tools coming into place, actions,
so
almost every service out there that has an API
they are able to connect.
There are AI AI systems that
are being built
for that communication to work,
um.
Now if we talk about legacy systems,
everyone has legacy systems in here and
they may don't have an API to be exposed
or they, they may have some kind of, you
know, legacy configuration and technical
depth that hasn't been worked on.
Then you definitely need to work around maybe
configuring some kind of wrappers APIs
around that and making sure you figure it
out, you know, how do you expose that
data into the uh
AI systems,
but as it is today and I, I
believe that more and more tools will become available.
You have multiple options
to interconnecting to your data sources,
so you have a full view
of how your enterprise data works
and that is kind of the context
key that you are able to pass
to all of your agentic workflows
and AI workflows,
you know, the better the context,
the better the response,
you know, uh,
models, the LLM models,
they are raw, they understand.
A lot of different things
we are looking into enterprise context.
That's why
bridging these data silos is key
to be able to have good success.
And of course, uh, so everyone has just done
that and we're in a great state now, right?
No, we are far, far away from that and
that's why MCP just came out a few
months ago we saw
a need in the market of how to integrate
and expose these tools to have access
to these
data silos in a different way.
You know, you bring up an excellent point
and I'm gonna tie this
back a little to what we just spoke about which
is. The real value
of AI coming when you reimagine
workflows, and workflows,
for the most part live in operational
systems.
What we're also seeing
is, in some cases, a
reluctance
For many reasons, but a reluctance
to
give access
to operational systems.
They are really guarded, right?
They're the, they're the jewels, and so no one wants to
give you access. So this
actually creates a tension,
if you think about it. On one side, we're talking about
agents, which can, you know, work in
a reimagined process. On the other
side, we're saying, no, no, no, all that is good,
but don't touch my system.
And funnily enough, at
least as an interim state,
what we're seeing in a few organizations
across industries
is
the
I won't call it the re-emergence, but the reimportance
of things such as a data lake
which we thought, listen, is gonna be passe
because now we're going into AI and agentic AI
lakes are gonna,
you know, go away.
No, they're not,
because in many organizations they're saying hang on.
Yes, you need data
because you need to get to context for your AI
to really work.
We will get you the data from our systems
and then you run that off of your lake in some
way, shape or form. Very interesting. So there are
all these interim architectures
which we are actually living through right now.
I, I think,
I think there's a a mistake
that, that I've made and that I've seen made
in the media, which is
people don't want to give up their, their
special operational data because they're
afraid their jobs are.
go away or whatever.
But I, I think psychologically
that misses the fact that we've been training those
teams that own mission critical operational data
to be incredibly secure about it,
very worried about its availability,
very worried about um
whether or not it's accurate, correct, and ready,
and it's almost that they don't trust
us to take it out of their
operational arm because they've had beaten into
them. For the last decade,
make sure it's perfect, make sure it's always working, make sure it's
always available, make sure the data is clean,
and they can't
trust us to do it. I, I think it's
less about, oh no, my job's gonna go away and
more about
this data is really important to our company.
Let's work together,
make sure that all that knowledge that you know
that you have, bring it into the AI ecosystem.
Yeah, Robbie, what I was trying to add
was I think.
I agree with you.
I think there's one set of folks like what you said,
right? They want the operation data,
but then probably there's some security
or or fear
on, on the job, uh, and so on.
But the other set I have
seen, what I have seen is that.
Probably, you know, they,
I mean,
the,
they're not into the A world
and hence they are really, really afraid
and probably they feel it's risky to
expose my data to the AI
and you know, with all the models
that we work with, we clearly
You know, have a policy. I think it is
putting the message as well saying that
no models will train using the enterprise
data and so on.
The other aspect is basically, you know.
Everybody going through the responsible AA
policies and trainings will also
help to alleviate
some of the problems that you are raising and so on. So, bring
them more awareness, in my opinion,
automatically,
they feel that, OK.
Well, and
we have this huge bias here.
You're an AI expert.
You're an AI expert. We're like, why are you not
helping us?
And they, and, and, but you also
quoted that a lot of these projects failed
number. I don't know if it's 90. Well,
like we could have a long discussion about whether or not that number is
correct, but I think the specter of failure is,
is weighing over their heads too. Like why should we
trust you and we.
What I think we see at Glean is that there are two
sets, if you just look at segmenting
people who are interested in us into two groups.
There's
those who are looking for a great AI solution
that come to us, cause they love our AI solution.
But the majority are people who are looking for a
solution, and it may or may not have
AI in it, right? And
we as AI experts immediately leap to
the AI is the solution
answer,
but uh they're just trying to solve a problem, they're
trying to solve a business problem, and, and we're like AI
AI AI, and they, I, I think there's some trust
we lose there too.
Do you want any questions from the audience?
Yeah, uh, so we just passed the halfway
mark here.
So, um, I do wanna encourage you to ask
any questions. So if anybody's got
them, probably the best way to do is
to holler them loudly,
and then I'll repeat them.
If anybody's got any specifically,
we've got a whole bunch of these slides with quotes on them, so we
can go all day,
but, uh, we wanna make it as useful to you as
possible.
All right, well don't be a stranger.
holler or come right up here and, and, and, and
ask us as, as we, um, as
questions arise in your head, we'd be happy to do it.
So, I want to pivot a little bit
to this next one because this is one
that's close to me as a Glean
person.
Um, that I think is a change
in what the industry is thinking about when they're thinking
about AI.
So Glen has built this
tool that allows people to very quickly and
efficiently make agents.
And yet when we look at the agents
which get the most use across our
customer base,
they're ones that have been built by specialists
over years.
Now, I built, I, look, I work at Glean, I
have agents I run every day that do all kinds of cool tasks
for me. It's very nice. I would love to show it off. It's fantastic.
But these really transformational
agents take time and work.
And so from this McKenzie study, I think it's really
interesting to think that like,
An individual
employee
is looking at a future where they can
use AI to make a recurrent
workflow or to make their life easier,
but that is seldom transformational
for an organization.
So Robbie, how do you think about like, who
do you let build agents? How do
those agents,
would you think about them being shared or if they're being
shared, or are you there yet? Like, like
how do you think about
who you let do that? How do you promote it to the
whole org, where does that innovation come from?
That's a, it's a thorny question that builds on our
idea of like organizational change too.
Yeah, absolutely.
Uh, as I mentioned, right, so I have been
on the AI journey,
specifically JA journey for the last, you
know, 3 to 4 years now,
and,
you know, when we started it, I could see,
you know, the reluctance to use the AI
and partly because they, we don't know, partly
because they are really afraid to use and so on.
Compared to where we started, you know, now,
you know, when I'm talking to the business people,
their interactions,
actually they are very well.
Now in developing Google Gyms,
I'll go to the agents
and that's where they started, right,
because the glean, the glean agents is
a recent, recent things for us,
but they are, there are some good people
from the business side I see
who created the gyms and, and then
shared the gyms also across
their organizations and so on.
And, and so we do have that internal
version of the J GPD kind,
um,
GPT that we developed even there
I think people started doing that.
When, when, when it comes to this one, there
are, you know, two types of agents
that we can build.
One is that no core agents is what I think
that Glen is is very good at it.
And there are,
you know, high code agents
or the medium code agents, so that's where the
sort of the crew A platform things seem to come
into the picture. But you know, for
that we need a lot of IT teams,
right? Who has uh the programming
knowledge of,
um, you know, going through multiple workflows
and things like that.
But I see,
you know, the business side is learning these type
of the,
you know, agents building is on the rise,
right? And I, you know, I, I
could clearly see them, they're trying to,
you know, come to me or my
team. Hey, this is the idea that I have it,
you know, can I run,
run it through the agents and so on. So,
so definitely
I see the, the changes happening
in the right direction.
But sometime, you know, we might need to help to some
extent, but one thing that I really
wanted to highlight
is basically,
you know, whoever
is actually building the skill set
specifically around the prompt and how
the context works,
the intricacies of the model, how do they,
you know, use the model for various purposes
with this specific context, I think they
are going to be the king.
And I have literally seen
the business is also trying to,
you know.
Bring the use cases and develop the agents.
So how many people out here have actually built
an agent themselves?
It's really OK. Oh good, lots of hands.
Excellent, yeah, I, I do. I think you're right. Like there's kind
of a pro code way of looking at this and a no
low code way of looking at this.
One thing, you know, I wanna highlight basically,
um, I was thinking that, um,
you know, my, my specific, I
don't want to name the organizations, I was thinking that
they are never going to be building the agents,
but. They themselves are coming
forward and then say, yeah, they are more sensitive
organizations and they say Ravi, you know, tell me how do
I build it. I want to use it and things,
which is a good sign
compared to where we started and things like that. But
as I said, it's a long way to go in
the journey. So, Rohit, how do you see
organizations?
Structuring themselves
to build, I guess, for lack of a better term,
an agent pipeline from sort of like
ideation to
like, have you seen that and, and, and how do you see
them sort of structuring how they work? Absolutely,
and I'll first answer
the question that you asked,
uh, literally is a billion dollar
question, which is who should be building your agents?
And the answer is
Deloitte Consulting Professional Services.
Oh wow. No, we
really are top, uh, on the top
right of the Gartner quadrant, look us up, but
that was a joke.
Um, you know, when I look at.
But when I look at um
this quote,
um this is actually a peek into
the future,
but it's not just a random peak.
There are these few promises
that agentic AI come with.
The first promise
is Abstraction of
complexity.
So whenever we're talking about building a
complex solution,
there's technical complexity, architectural
complexity, coding complexity, what have you.
And so,
this promise of being able to abstract
that out
is huge, number one.
The second thing is,
when you build a solution, as probably
almost all of you know,
we usually involves
all kinds of data and lots and lots of
data. So,
autonomous data management
is another promise
of agentic AI.
And then last but not least,
What these agents really do
is they plan,
they reason,
and they execute.
If you take all these three things
together,
it naturally leads you to
a situation where users can leverage
these promises, as I call them.
And now maybe in the future, even
even communicate in just
natural language,
focus on higher value tasks such as
business requirements and business logic.
Of course there's a place for human in the loop in all
of this,
but you know, you see where I'm going with this, an
evolution to where
more and more
business side employees
will be able to create these kinds of
solutions. Are they gonna create super complex,
uh, solutions? Is that gonna happen next
year? Neither, I don't think so,
but this is a very futuristic,
but a very plausible look at, you know,
how things are gonna evolve. Yep.
So Marcel, when you've looked across companies that are
doing this.
How much trust
does a company have in letting an
individual build an agent and
do autonomous
things,
or well, or, or individual things with,
with corporate data.
Uh, I mean, are, are they letting her do that?
Are they letting every rank and file person do it? I mean, we're
a glean, so they let us all do whatever we want with agents
because we're playing with it all day long. But what
are you seeing out in the real world?
Yeah, there are two different perspectives. One
is
let it loose and start creating agents,
and the chances are that it will
become a problem in the future,
uh, duplicate agents, agents
without the real context, without the real authorization.
And the second one is put in some
kind of governance in place,
um, but just taking
a step back,
um,
the way I approach on my
conversation with customers is like a kind of a three
step approach. One is enablement.
You need to enable these business users
what is the concept of building agents goes
back to how to create a prompt,
what are the best practices,
you know, having like internal documentation,
uh, internal library of best prompts.
Then the second one is about
having guardrails in place, technical
guardrails into what doc, what
access are you giving these um
employees to create these agents, what
will be the data sources,
and then the third one is
business users.
Have so much knowledge about these processes
and workflows they've been doing this on a daily
basis across multiple
solutions open an Excel spreadsheet,
then going into a CRM,
putting all that together, doing pivot tables
so there is
so much knowledge of how
to implement these
that the understanding of the how
a human will do it
needs to be implemented on the process of
creating an agent.
Every time
I'm talking with customers,
as soon as they start talking about the business
outcome,
my first question is like how would a human
do it? Can you walk me through how one of
your employees do it and then we
can start talking about the technical
parts of how to do it,
uh. So that will be,
I think that the, the three main components
of how to
enable
business users to start creating
agents
and of course
having the guardrails um and
the security.
I go back to
security team is your best friend.
The earliest you get them into the
process, the more quickly you will move,
um, uh, implementing
uh agentic AI.
That's, that's, that's a truism of business process automation.
Can you do it once,
because if you can't do it once I can't automate it, right? Like
it doesn't work like that. Yeah, Ravi, let me just add it because
right now I'm in the middle of developing
an agent
sharing governance strategy
because this year has been the, you know, agentic
world and so on. So the,
the real problem is,
you know, not deciding who
can create the agents
but what the agent can do
and who it will be shared with.
Is it going to be shared with 5 to 6
people just as a digital
assistant for themselves,
or is it going to be shared at the
department level, like 2 to 3000
people will use it,
or is it going to be shared at the company
level where, you know, 7 or 10,
tens of thousands of people can use it and things
like that? But that's where I think
you know
my friend Marshall says, right,
security is the number one friend for you
but not just security, right? So
if somebody's going to develop
an agent for HR for hiring
process or recruitment or whatever, right,
the performance lighting and things like that,
that's becoming.
You know, a, a bigger topic,
right, because now how do you ensure
that it's not hallucinating? How do
you ensure that it's not biasing, or
can the manager take the agent and
run with that
and then just write it just like, you know, what
the agent give the answer? What if it was wrong?
And
I, I think that a lot goes in
the agent sharing, so it's not
about just who can create it.
But where the complexity comes in,
who are you going to share with and what's
the process you have around,
um,
you know, the
the coalitioning governance and so on. I, I
love what you're saying there because I think
when I think about it philosophically, right, so first of all you
have to have guardrails so nobody breaks anything. I think
that's the baseline, right?
But, uh, philosophically I think about
it like a software person. I think what
we, we have to do is think about this as we're
creating software assets.
And Glen subscribes to the,
we're not better than anybody else mentality
when we're doing this. We ask a lot of questions of our
customers that lets us know what we should build,
so that we're building things that are useful, and
that's the same mentality we have to bring here,
right, which is
What are they, to Marcel's point, they
know what's needed, they know how it works.
It is impossible to pretend
that me as an IT person
who's who's inserted into this department
is gonna magically be a genius in the department,
right? So, so I liked what you said about
who's its shared with, Robbie, I think that's really important,
right? We need the innovation on
the individual side
to. identify what needs to be done and to
build that prototype.
But then we also need someone who is an
expert to look at that prototype,
harden it, refine it,
and promote it to the organization in a way
that it is then
usable and shareable and repeatable.
And I don't think we can get away with either
half, but I think
organizations fail when they assume the
user in the business will independently create
it and it'll work out great. I think that's a
failure mode, but I think the other failure mode is IT
will make it and push it into your org,
and that is another failure mode, right? Like these
two sides have to work together. You, you, you're
just spot on it. That's where
the, the governance structure,
you know, we are in the process of creating it.
Yeah, you know, like just to
like in the traditional model,
like you said, it was IT creating
solutions and rolling them out in the business using them.
Here, we're going all the way to the
other end of the spectrum
and saying
business is gonna create
and, you know, and then all the,
everything that we spoke about in terms of governance, etc.
comes into play.
I really think,
you know, as we get to maturity,
in this particular AI case,
um I think we will probably
end up with some kind of an
organizational construct where you have,
for lack of a better term,
an AICOE.
Which is more of an enabler in
organizations. So you still have business
side employees building stuff,
but it is in a very governed way
with the right tooling and the right processes.
And everything that goes with it and then we're seeing that
in a ton of our customers, right?
We're seeing that there's, there's an AI expert who works
alongside the business expert to,
to just first of all identify it.
Um, there is some interesting thoughts
here though that, that, uh, that AI
is bringing.
So we have an agent that we, we run internally
these days which is what agent should I build agents.
It looks at all the things I do all day in
the context of what I'm up to, and it says,
hey, you might want to identify the
following workflows that you did yesterday.
That's a really interesting thought that
AI is now being used
to make that AI go,
right? And Marcel, you mentioned prompts too.
So quick show of hands, who's taking prompt
engineering classes?
OK, we got some hands up.
Great. Why?
Well, well,
who's familiar with the term prompt engineering?
OK, all the many, many hands. Alright.
So prompt engineering is
learning how to write, to write and ask
the correct questions of AI to get the
correct answers back, right? So that's why we take prompt
engineering. Um,
so why is AI so dumb that it can't ask
you to clarify when you give it something
that's ambiguous?
Well, it, it can be.
And so this next generation of AI that we're
seeing is actually,
um, when you write a bad agent.
There's a possibility that that agent then says, you know,
you didn't write me very well.
Can we clean me up and fixes it
or writes itself?
Yeah, uh, this ambiguity is becoming
critical even on the foundational
models
today when you do create a prompt and
send it to a foundational model,
one of the first steps they run is
how ambiguous is this question? How
can I improve it?
What is really the content and the intent
of the end user
and that's what normally is passed to the LLM
to create the response.
So more and more we're working on
trying to
break that ambiguity around
how the prompt is created.
Yeah, when you ask questions of an AI,
the first thing it should do is.
Interrogate the question you asked and
figure out what you're looking for and know more about
you so there's a whole context angle there that's, that's
really super important.
All right, so we're coming up towards the end
here, so all your many
questions are flowing in.
If you have any, please feel free to ask them.
Um, like I said, I, I put in so many
quotes here we could go for the next week if,
if you're willing to sit with us.
Um, so let's talk a little bit about value
first,
um, in the last say 10 minutes
of what we have here.
So, KPMG did a
little bit of a study to figure out when
we're gonna see the results of AI and, and its
value, and they said it's achieved
incrementally. I think as
AI biased people sitting here on the
stage talking AI we're all like, yay, AI
is the answer, there's some magic there.
How do you view Robbie in your org?
Measuring, quantifying.
Value that you actually get and
how do you
properly set expectations upwards
that this isn't a panacea or a magic
wand? Like, how do you think about
conveying that knowledge both down into the organ,
up into, to management?
Yeah, I mean, this is one of the most
challenging
uh task today.
I am actually asked to build a dashboard.
That will say the value the
tools are bringing to the organization. I'm
really, really struggling, right,
because today,
you know, most of the tools that what we
built it are, um, you know, what
we purchased and rolled out
are actually very good in telling in
terms of
the effective utilization.
OK, how many people are using it, how
long they used it,
and so on,
but he doesn't tell
what for they used it because we are not supposed to
go and look at what people are doing it,
or, you know, how, you know, what
value it brought it
and things like that. So
we are still brainstorming specifically on this
topic. Um, I, I don't think that my answer
is, you know, going to be very, very helpful,
but, but some, you know,
if he knows, you know, somebody maybe.
I'm eager to learn as well. Well, we
have a hard time generally as an industry measuring
productivity.
So the first question for this should always be,
so how do you measure productivity without AI?
I can deploy AI and we can
see if it changes that number, and then people are like, Well, I don't
really know that either, right? So yeah, sorry, right.
I was going to add to what you said, which is
This entire notion about
Value measurement.
On tooling
I feel when it comes to AI energetic
AI
is
is not the right question.
That we're looking at.
If the entire premise
of AI is to
re-engineer business processes,
then all those use cases that you're gonna
identify
should have a very robust
set of KPIs
built in right, even before you start building
anything, to say, here is how I'm going
to measure value uplift.
And so the value uplift is
from a business perspective,
measured that much more
easily,
quote unquote, right?
As opposed to saying,
hey, how's my tooling doing
and is that really a measure of value.
So, I think that is huge.
Um,
and, and we are actually, what we do is we embed
change management just in its
entirety,
you know, value is just one part of
it. It is,
it is the
upskilling. It is actually
a target state operating model which looks
very different from what you have today.
It is,
how do I communicate and make sure
that people are A, not freaked out,
and B, they're truly, truly, you know, users
are truly adopting once you start rolling
things out. So, there's a whole host
of threads
which goes into
change management, specifically when it comes to
AI
and agentic AI.
And that as a part of our
approach is front and center.
So very, very
purposefully when we stand up
teams to develop AI
solutions in different organizations,
we actually call it the right side and the left side of
the brain working together where we
have business teams.
With change management value and all of that,
and technology teams working hand
in hand with the organization's
users and other teams as well. You know, I think
I think
sometimes this business value focused
consulting gets a bad name because it's,
can be a little soft and we're all nerds, so we're like,
so that's great, but how do you automate it, right? Like,
um, but it's so important in AI
because of the synthetic nature of what AI
is doing that's really important and to your point. Point Marcel you're
talking about we need to make sure we're talking to security
when we get started we also need to be, I
think talking to the business as well,
setting the right expectations,
uh, not only from the technical perspective but
from the business perspective and
from leadership perspective,
um. I have
had multiple conversations that leadership is
a one full adoption of AI
agentic solutions
and it's like, but what, what,
how are you measuring that just by clicking on
an agent
or the value that that agent is giving you
and if you're gonna measure the value, what are you
really looking to it? Let's go back to KPIs
or is about time saved
is about the quality of the outcome.
It's also a feedback loop that
needs to be put from the end user
perspective. We need that feedback from the
end user is like, is this agent really
helping me on my workflows?
How can I improve it?
Oh, is hallucinating.
How can I reduce that kind of hallucination?
So there's also need to be a feedback loop from
the agent, from the user and user
perspective for us to be able to measure,
uh, better the quality of what we're building.
OK, lightning round because we're almost done here.
OK, Robbie, so we have all these people
here and they're all thinking about AI.
Uh, what's the one thing they should all
know about slash worry about slash do?
Can you repeat the question? Yeah, so, so if
there's one thing that you would want all these people to take
away so that they could be successful when
they do AI, like what's that one
thing, and you have to, you have to encapsulate it in like 30
seconds, and you're allowed to pass to Rohit to make him
answer first if you want, you know, I'm good. So
one day, you know, it is definitely
adding value, so you have to take a little
bit of risk to that. But at the same time,
make sure that you have
enough guard rails built in.
I would say focus on business value.
This entire
uh genre of
technology, if you will, when it comes to AI energetic
AI machine learning,
I mean, the focus has to be on
Truly on solving business problems,
and that's really when you look at it from a business
lens, is when you'll truly be able to do
a whole bunch of things,
including actually
success of your use cases and your re-engineering.
As well as measure value, so value,
value, value, I said 3 things,
OK, Marcel, you're last at the company whose
tagline is work AI that actually
works.
Absolutely start small,
make sure that you have governance in place.
Make sure that you understand,
understand your context.
Don't index too much on
what is the model you're using,
but what is the enterprise data
that you have.
And that you have guardrails and governance
around that, but start small and
bring security
from day one, bring security from day one.
So look, I, I wanna say thank you to
everyone who managed to make it here on day four who
came to join us,
um, so thank you so much. We're at booth 1333
if you're back at the Venetian today, which should only take
what, an hour in a cab, so you're good.